hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play the things in the night my
name is markiplier and we are in the
castle of Doom and death and destruction
and dismemberment not sure about that
last part but I'm dismemberment in the
town very much so and I think there's
anything over here actually oh nothing
Oh something up there nope uh-uh
no oh yeah okay so we're just gonna move
forward it ah mannequins just go so
don't stand in the goop okay there we go
oh no more goop not many custom stories
I've seen never used the goop so
pulsating the gross yeah Kim your head
here okay
well ah how'd you get there look what
the hell two points yeah we're doing
good
couple NT of oil yes open more slowly
and creepily why don't you I feel like
I'm obligated to check all these in it
for that oh yeah I'm obligated awesome
don't like him don't like woo okay
chairs Oh
multiple chairs I like it yes now what
happened here like yeah ah hello baby
who you look so fun mmm yeah you too
baby you do now now look words I'm not
gonna like that what a waste that would
be if I spent all my tinder box is lie
to God
alright there's nothing over here anyway
wait if I click wait oh ha ha I changed
my mind about the lighting thing
obviously oh okay now moving on
you know don't do Wow Zedan orb I can't
take that lion all right I don't see
anything here that's useful I'm up here
here I don't see anything yeah it's a
lot of nothing
okay whatever I'll just carry on then go
over there what's going on what is this
deal hello can i I saw a hand okay there
might be some switch or something
that opens it nothing I don't see you
switch though I kind of wondered without
seeing anything so I'll go up okay back
to the goop yeah okay so I'm obligated
to check all of these nope uh-huh
nothing anything what
oh you're stuck okay what's that
no nothing for me oh don't change yeah
[Applause]
nope you didn't change this is weirdest
thing I keep like seriously they haven't
changed that ah
stop it they haven't changed that
picture since I played the original
image oh come on
aha Oh can't hide from me behind the
stairs
I always check behind the stairs Oh take
that I suppose good nothing I've got gas
there was no key or anything any useful
story no all right hello limbo ow my
face it's in my hair all right I didn't
find anything like that door was locked
and like I got nothing else back there
this is to the catacombs and it's locked
okay there must have been something in
the other wing that I missed I don't
know it's easy to get turned around I
suppose
well not turned around it's easy to get
you t'see how to miss stuff I wish them
to stop one thing I don't like about the
group it's just random like spurts in
your eye and spins ok so there's got to
be something in here that can open that
portcullis gate now was there anything
here when this smashed
no hello baby I know I know I know you
miss me but I gotta go I gotta find the
secret baby gots to find her secret
there's a puzzle and I will solve it my
hand up there don't know what that's all
about throw a charity yeah take your
head off take your head off
yeah okay see anything up the lines what
in the piano's what in that nice app
what
I've checked all the butts there's
nothing has absolutely dick doodlee just
this orb here oh yeah I'm busting your
[ __ ] what's gonna do okay I guess
nothing let me think let me think think
think think think use my brain we almost
I think with the chairs maybe there's
something on the chairs like a key i
play not Oh
how many of you saw that and was like
screaming at me raise your hand
yeah I deserve that - bring it on
Brent yeah I deserve that how do I keep
missing the one that brings back the
pride to my brothers will open the way
but the Queen's must be served first
beware of the Guardians and lurk and is
walls for they are there no one is too
faded to breed the best okay
obviously that's catacombs looks like I
need two orbs identical to the ones at
the lines and the Angels pedestals when
I find them I need to make sure the
first first put one at the aims of
pedestals then other one at the lines I
think then of course unser of my main
ladies first
always always of course you know they're
not my main ladies you beautiful women
out there I know I know I know
don't think I've forgotten about you
because I know that painting gonna
change hmm uh-huh Alexander Graham oh
man it feels like forever since I've
played the original amnesia Technic
all right oh I hate I just know when the
levels are designed like this it means
bad news
yep okay I'm not gonna go that way
was that by me oh oh no oh no I thought
those actual monster oh yeah no man I
swear the environments in this place are
so detailed like everything about it is
involves the matters this guy really put
the time into making sure that
everything was like had it life to the
room even though their death a lot death
to this room but you know what I mean ah
haha hide from me I'm so great
Bulls ki bollocks bollocks the [ __ ]
Bulls key is anything else I'm so great
Oh
I'm the best
it's a lagging a bit down here
ha ha no ha ha no why's it gotta be the
boost man Oh
stay back I'm scarier than you are
ah
[Music]
I don't like moves bad I've never had a
good experience we move man I mean the
end of Gary dark secrets that was moose
man they're gonna I wonder if they're
gonna bring back any monsters in a
machine for pigs or if they're just
gonna make new one because the Moose man
is very iconic and just perfect monster
ice and he's low don't fix it
miss Parkins stand in the dark of this
closet it hasn't changed yet he might
just be patrolling the halls which I
would hate blood dribbling from the
ceilings there's nothing okay
alright I'm gonna assume that he's at
least gone from the air oh my
ha ha ha oh oh oh ha ha
ok this is awful that is like terrible
that's pretty damn bad I'm getting out
of here I don't like to be in that room
that's a bad room
he's still there what where oh oh why oh
there's too many monsters I said I could
deal with the monsters monsters are okay
but they don't go away
please don't go
having bust down that door yet they
might not have heard me come in I don't
know
I can hear the Moose man he's right
outside that door
whoa ah you had no reason no reason to
bust down that door
you had no reason oh oh man is standing
in the darkness it's gonna eat up my
sanity oh you had no reason no reason
you did I just hear the chase squeal
yeah no reason none I think I hear the
grunt Oh
[Music]
can they get me in closets I don't know
oh I'm losing my mind
ah they're both here I can do nothing I
need that grunt leave
oh maybe oh no was I supposed to get
something there and get out of here
I didn't look around I just jumped in
their closet okay's the grunt gone oh oh
they're gone oh oh nothing we're gonna
go away oh I thought they weren't oh
he's still there what I can get it
anyway yeah okay maybe I can do justice
stuck oh how about this John
[Music]
yeah this isn't working
ah ha ha come on you can't make this
work why won't that work ah that should
have worked ok never mind that's
something right here let me read this ah
no actually I'm way over time so sorry
I'm a lot of time for this episode so
thank you all so much for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
part
bye bye